[Music]
but right now comic-con is clearly the
place to be
more than 130,000 fans of comics movies
and science fiction are going to pack
this event over the next four days
there's gonna be 850 panels and fans
losing their minds not just the fans
Hollywood - and here's just a taste of
what to expect expect hollywood's wonder
women led by gal gadot to take flight
the sequel Wonder Woman 1984 has been in
production for weeks we predict gal and
director patty Jenkins will hit the
Warner Brothers presentation stage and
deliver a sneak peak Gau might even
bring another young fan to tears like
last year and expect the call keeping to
help
Aquaman make a splash
the film's first trailer will debut
Saturday director James Wan posted this
image of the Oscar winner playing Jason
Momoa 's mother Queen Atlanta your mom
is Nicole Kidman it was hands down when
the greatest actress and Jason will help
represent the super dads dominating
comic-con Chris Pratt will likely arrive
Saturday to promote the lego movie -
that same day proud papa Ryan Reynolds
will reunite with his Deadpool - family
for an on-stage panel it's speculated
Reynolds may even confirm news of a
Deadpool 3 dad of two sterling K Brown
will also hit our et sweet he makes his
comic-con debut for the upcoming action
film the predator there will also be
plenty of Halloween nostalgia from a
former scream queen he's waited for me
tomorrow Jamie Lee Curtis is confirmed
to appear during the universal panel
speaking of throwbacks earlier today the
cast of the new CW charmed reboot kicked
off the whole convention
[Applause]
you